bringing republican senator tom
continent of arkansas senator nice to
see you again and good morning to you
in washington well what's the chance
that the
chinese government ever conceived of
this i i would suggest zero
and if that is the case what does this
administration willing to do
to make china pay for it
yeah i think bill you're right that
chinese china
chances of ever conceding they're
responsible for this virus is zero
but that new report from the lawrence
livermore lab just confirms what i've
been saying from the very beginning just
use your common sense this virus emerged
in a city larger than new york just a
few blocks down the road from the lab
where they research
these viruses every bit of evidence we
have points to those labs
and it's past time to hold china
accountable for their negligence
and their deceitfulness in unleashing
this plague on the world
there's lots of things we could do we
could revoke their permanent most
favored nation status a bad mistake
that we made 20 years ago we could team
up with our allies and take back the
very favorable financing terms they get
from international financial
institutions like the world bank
we can take away visas from chinese
communist party members and their kids
so they can't send their kids to
american schools anymore
there's no end to the things we can do
to make china pay for unleashing this
plague and we should start right now
betsy mckagie over at the new york post
wrote this today that biden needs to
make china pay for its actions over
covet
saying that biden should be leading a
multinational effort to isolate china
get answers and demand reparations so
he's got an opportunity
because tomorrow on wednesday he leaves
to go and meet with the eu countries
and some of them are not necessarily on
board with holding china accountable but
that might be
the best place to start
yeah that'd be a great place to start
dana he's going to be meeting with their
allies in europe a lot of them have
economic interests tied up in china but
also europe is starting to get tired of
china as well you know they signed a
trade deal with china at the end of last
year
they've stopped the implementation of it
in part because of china
china's gross human rights abuses
against its own people so this really is
a right time to bring our allies along
with us
in isolating china and imposing real
consequences on them for unleashing this
plague on the world
senator i want to take you back in time
about a year and a half here's a series
of
media takes going after you you were
quite public on the possibility of this
early on just
listen to this on a very specific
question for you to follow
watch senator tom cotton suggested that
the virus may have come from
china's biological warfare program it's
very dangerous
to stir up suspicions rumors and spread
them among the people
cotton has been criticized by public
health professionals for giving just the
whiff of credibility there on television
and on social media to a conspiracy
theory
so that is february of 2020 what day did
you go public
and why where were you getting your
information that might lead you to
suggest that this was a lab leak
very early on i mean
bill i just used common sense i mean the
china
chinese communist party pointed to an
open-air food market
as the origin of this virus but they
didn't even sell bats in that
market early reports from well-respected
scientific journals said that there were
more people who got the virus with no
contact with that market than who got it
with contact that market
and as i've said this virus didn't
emerge in some remote rural village in a
mountain next to a cave full of bats
it emerged in a city larger than new
york just down the road
from labs where we know that they were
conducting very dangerous research into
coronaviruses
so all of the spin you just heard from
reporters and journalists on other
networks
was just partly because it was coming
from me it's partly because all those
networks are owned by or affiliated
with big hollywood studios who want
access to the chinese market
so they're deeply in the pocket of the
chinese communist party
i was intrigued by something you said
about what we could do to the chinese in
terms of making them pay for something
and one of them was about not allowing
their children to study here in american
universities
because that that obviously is a
covenant they want they want to come
here and a lot of these universities
want the chinese to come here because
they pay full freight out of state
tuition
but is that something you think you
might be able to get some traction on
we should why should we be subsidizing
america's higher education institutions
when they turn around and accept the
princeling kids of all these chinese
communists because that's the reality of
it
most people who come here in america are
well connected in china
i'm not saying necessarily they're the
kids of the senior leaders of china
although those come too
but any local communist apparatchik has
a much better chance of sending their
kids to study at our universities or our
private high schools
that's something they really want and if
that's if we cut off visas
for those chinese communist officials
and their family members
that will impose real consequences on
them
for what they've done to the world
that's interesting thank you
tom cotton we'll talk again thanks for
your time today hi everyone i'm brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe
right now